es gibt viel zu tun und keine zeit zu
verlieren weiters war jesus arbeitet
ohne unterlass seitdem die
bundestagswahl ihr einen platz in
deutschlands geschichtsbüchern beschert
hat die in eritrea geborene anwältin war
schon lange in der kommunalpolitik aktiv
bis ein rassistischer anschlag in ihrem
bundesland ihr weltbild erschütterte ich
weiß nicht warum hanau hat bei mir ein
punkt erreicht wo ich einfach das gefühl
hatte jetzt geht nichts mehr jetzt muss
sich was ändern ich halte es nicht mehr
aus zehn menschen wurden bei dem
attentat getötet neun von ihnen mit
migrationsgeschichte
überkommen von dem gefühl dass
deutschland kein sicherer ort für sie
und ihre familie mehr ist er wirkt sie
das land zu verlassen
zur wahrheit gehört auch dass es schwer
ein land zu finden welches rassismus
frei ist
von daher war die nächste option wir
bleiben hier
aber geben alles was wir können um gegen
diskriminierung und rassismus
anzukämpfen
hier im ländlichen nordhessen ist eine
schwarze frau auf dem wahlzettel noch
etwas außergewöhnliches aber der mangel
an vorbildern war sogar ansporn für die
47 jährige denn für sie ist sichtbarkeit
im parlament
wenn unsere schüler in den schulen die
schüler ein drittel ein viertel
migrationshintergrund haben warum haben
wir das nicht auf der lehrerseite sollte
es sein finde ich möchte mich als
schüler in auch gespiegelt sehen bei den
lehrerinnen und genauso in den behörden
genauso in unseren parlamenten
doch während die deutsche gesellschaft
immer diverser wird hielten die
institutionen im land statistisch noch
hinterher der bundestag hat 736
mitglieder
83 von ihnen haben wurzeln im ausland
26 prozent der deutschen bürger innen
haben migrationsgeschichte im parlament
sind es allerdings nur elf prozent
weniger als die hälfte dieser
abgeordneten sind frauen und biskys war
jesus gewählt wurde gab es unter ihnen
keine einzige schwarze stimme
aus ihrem beschaulichen wahlkreis direkt
in die machtzentrale berlins dass die
erste schwarze frau erst 2021 in den
bundestag einzieht ist für sie kein
wunder weil wir einfach strukturellen
rassismus haben in diesem land und wenn
wir sagen es ist egal dann verschließen
wir unsere augen vor diesen
strukturellen problemen dann sind wir
nicht bereit zu sehen dass ich als
schwarze frau andere bedingungen habe
andere hört habe als eine frau die nicht
schwarz ist egal wie qualifiziert ich
bin noch kommt es bei jesus nur in den
bundestag um ihre post zu holen aber sie
kann es kaum erwarten endlich loszulegen
ja meine hoffnung ist natürlich dass wir
das thema chancengleichheit
weiterhin im mittelpunkt stellen die
auch
sensibilisieren bewusstsein schaffen
aber auch inhaltlich etwas bewegen die
neue abgeordnete hat viele pläne doch
ihr größtes anliegen ist es für andere
das vorbild zu sein dass sie selbst nie
hatte